We're here with the amazing Claire Foy
and Paul Bettany, the new stars of "A Very British Scandal",
although there's nothing "new star" about you,
you are both extremely established, hmm.
So a good way to say "You're both very old". (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Okay, well, in wanting to get to know
both of you a little bit better,
sometimes I like some sort of like,
you know, different questions,
not about work, not about family,
just about you.
Will you guys play a round of Final Five with me?
100%
Yes.
(audience applauds)
It's time for Final Five.
(drum fill crashes)
All right.
(audience applauds)
Claire, it's midnight.
You're at the fridge, you can't control yourself.
What's your late night snack?
Oh.
I'm really low rent
so basically, anything that was in there.
(Drew laughs)
Anything old and with mold on it, I'd probably eat.
I'm so sorry, I'm gross.
No.
Anything.
Anything?
Yeah.
Do you have a favorite food?
Sweet things, so there was like a pie or a cake
or a baked item, that wouldn't normally be in the fridge,
but it's in the fridge, apparently.
So I would eat that baked item in the fridge.
Well, I motor boated some food at midnight the other day.
(both laugh)
And it was so fun.
I was like, "How about just some toast and jam?" (gobbles)
Okay.
Paul, whose posters were covering your wall,
other than Jennifer Connelly,
you know, on your walls as a kid?
(Drew squeals and laughs)
(audience laughs)
Duran Duran.
Oh my God!
(audience applauds)
Duran Duran.
That's great.
I was gonna try and say something cool,
like The Jam or something,
but the truth is it was Simon Le Bon.
I mean, we had the same bedroom, Paul.
We had the same posters.
Yes.
Jennifer Connelly and Duran Duran.
I was so in love with Duran Duran.
They were my everything.
Yeah.
Hey, we have something in common, I love this.
Okay, Claire, what is your worst habit?
Um, all of the ones that everyone else has.
The boring ones, like looking up people
on the internet you shouldn't do.
(Drew cackles)
Oh, I like that one, fun Google searches.
Okay.
Paul, which member of the Royal family
would you wanna go to brunch with if you could?
Henry the VIII (laughs)
(Claire laughs)
(audience applauds)
I like that.
That'd be great.
I wasn't going there in my mind.
Eat a chicken leg.
I went current.
(both mimic gnashing)
You went history.
Very smart.
Okay, to both of you,
what's your rainy day activity?
If it's raining outside, what are you doing?
Ooh, beer.
Beer?
(audience laughs)
Yeah. (laughs)
I love you.
Definitely beer, yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, with a beer chaser.
Duvets.
Like being under a duvet, watching things on't telly.
Watching Patrick Swayze in "Ghost".
Ooh, yeah!
(audience laughs)
Maybe with some beer?
I dunno.
Yup.
His name is Sam in that movie.
(Paul laughs)
I love that movie so much.
I just watched it with my daughters.
They love that movie, I'm with you.
A duvet, a nice cocktail,
a little like something on the tube.
A whole day, a whole day can go by under that duvet.
I bet it can.
(Claire cackles)
And if you wanna see all of these yummy chemistries
and details and rich characters
and history and all of it,
then please watch "A Very British Scandal"
because it is available to stream on Prime Video,
this April 22nd.
Paul and Claire,
I have been looking so forward to speaking with you
and meeting two people that I'm such a psycho fan of.
(they laugh)
Thank you Claire Foy and Paul Bettany!
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
Thank you, Drew!
Thank you, Drew.
(bright theme music)